представники близько 50 країн візьмуть
участь 20 січня у засіданні контактної
групи Rammstein у Німеччині щоб вирішити
питання надання військової допомоги
Україні Київ розраховує на постачання
танків та бронетехніки для ЗСУ і ось
чому
українське солдати на фронті на Сході та
півдні України мають набагато менше
танків ніж у російських окупантів від
початку російського вторгнення Київ
вимагає від західних партнерів бойові
машини піхоти на кшталт німецьких
мардерів або американських Бредлі і ось
нарешті на початку січня їх пообіцяли
надати БМП доставляють піхотинців на
поле бою німецький експерт з питань
України Мюнхенської конференції з
безпеки ніколанги вже давно закликає
надати Україні такі танки
бойові машини піхоти можуть безпечно
доставляти піхотинців на передову та
здійснювати маневри і звичайно у них є
зброя також протитанкова зброя для
самозахисту але також для використання в
атаці
Франція погодилася поставити в Україні
свої легкі броньовані розвідувальні
машини
mx-10rсі вони колісні надзвичайно
маневрені і можуть використовуватись на
передовій для розвідки ворожих позицій
в Україні доводиться воювати проти
ворога який дуже сильний в артилерії для
формування єдиного бойового порядку для
потужних ударних сил необхідно
інтегрувати бойові машини піхоти разом з
бойовими танками та іншими елементами
бойовими танками на кшталт-челленджер-2
які тепер обіцяє Великобританія або
німецький Леопард 2 Польща Перша країна
яка пообіцяла Україні бойовий танк з
важким озброєнням німецького виробництва
за умови що Німеччина погодиться
уже з червня Минулого року на лінії
фронту в Україні використовується
Західна далекобійна артилерійська зброя
панцер гаубіца 2000 з Німеччини та
Нідерландів
йдеться про інтеграцію різних типів
озброєнь і транспортних засобів для
створення потужної сили здатної прорвати
навіть добре укріплену лінію фронту це
саме те що зараз потрібно Україні
говорять про так званий
загальновійськовий бій це стратегія
ведення бою яку НАТО відпрацьовувала ще
під час холодної війни з далекобійною
артилерією в тилу такою як панцер
гаубиця 2000
бойові машини піхоти з яких солдати
забезпечують вогневий захист своїх
бойових танків
а саме бойових танків на кшталт
Challenger 2 обіцяних великобританією
або німецьких леопард-2
в Україні військові стратеги переконані
що це дозволить їм компенсувати
російську перевагу в кількості
новобранців військової техніки гранат і
ракет
так вважає і відомий військовий блогер і
Гал Левін колишній офіцери ізраїльської
армії зазначає що російські війська
також намагаються вести
загальновійськовий бій
Росія продемонструвала в Україні що вона
не вміє ввести загальновійськовий бій
вона намагалася реалізувати цю концепцію
Але у них це виходить максимально погано
тому що для загальновійськового бою
окрім грамотності командирів вам
потрібні також і добре налагоджений
зв'язок і координація між підрозділами А
у російську армії ганебну налагоджений
зв'язок і координації між цими
підрозділами чому Росію успадкувала
армію скелет оргструктури від Радянської
армії
культуру от Советской Армии однак Кремль
вочевидь проаналізував помилки 2022-го
міністр оборони Росії оголосив
реструктуризацію збройних сил до того ж
Україна повинна готуватися до нової
масованої атаки подібної до тієї що
сталася навесні 2022 року у війні таку
інтенсивності масштабу завжди не
вистачає техніки У вас немає ніякого
порогу а техніка має йти потоком поки
Україна не вийде на кордони 91-го року і
не розгромить армію Росії танки
броньовані бойові машини артилерія
снаряди все повинні йти потоку
саме тому Україна просить у заходу
дедалі більше танків щоб мати можливість
перемогти російську армію за допомогою
загальновійськового бою